so this show is so addictive i'm sure
people have been telling you that
all day i mean from the first episode on
i was like my new favorite show yes it
is
um no it's true this show is being
billed as you know
gossip girl of the regency area um or
yeah
or era phoebe would you say that that's
a an accurate description that this show
is being described as gossip girl meets
regency era
uh yeah in some ways i think you know
the aspect of lady whistle down and
these anonymous this anonymous voice
that we hear which is the wonderful
julie andrews of course
and i think there definitely is that
aspect and and the fact that they're
following sort of these young
people's lives in their coming of age
and watching them uh
you know get into all sorts of trouble
and and all sorts of different
love affairs going on so yeah there's
definitely an aspect and element of
gossip girl
um but i i definitely think it's very
much its own world isn't it
like nothing i've ever seen before it's
it's
it's a sort of regency um
in a whole new light i think
um you know this is shonda rhimes first
big project with netflix there's so much
anticipation uh surrounding this show
uh reggae you worked on uh for the
people which of course is another shonda
rhimes show um
was was she a big draw for you wanting
to be a part of this show
yeah i mean i've been working with these
guys for a while so there's lots of
people that i know and love and
admire the work of in the company um so
it was a bit of a no-brainer to stick
around when they said hey we've got this
thing that we're working on
that we'd love you to read and i had a
look at it we had a bunch of meetings
and we talked about all the
opportunities that there were to do
something new
in this time period to do something
people don't expect um in what's
otherwise
known as quite a traditional genre and
bring all of that 21st century
shondaland flavor to it
bring all of that color bring all of
that excitement that speed wit
sexiness fun um and so it was a very
easy
decision to make and what's so fun with
both of your characters
is you don't really get along at the
very beginning so how do you find that
balance between that tension
and then that just natural chemistry
because your chemistry on screen is fire
thank you i think we just don't realize
we get along
was it kind of fun building that
relationship between your characters
just you know right off the bat
yeah it was great and and we we were
able to do it
with the help of i mean firstly the
stories are so rich and obviously
it's all there on the page um and then
it was just bringing it to life and we
had an incredible choreographer
uh jack murphy who sort of helped to
choreograph or did choreograph the
the dance sequences throughout the show
which was sort of our starting point um
when me and regates came together and
started rehearsing for the first time
that was where we were thrown into so
that was where we built a lot of that
that you know we really found our
footing in that sense it was sort of
like a rehearsal room my feet
yeah we found each other's feet um
but no it was really it was really
helpful um
to find that chemistry and then and we
spent i mean so much time together
rehearsing so by the time we we
eventually got to set
um we we were good to go
um reggae what is it about both of your
characters that there is just this
intense chemistry like what is it about
these two personalities
um i mean as phoebe said we're very
lucky to have inherited characters that
people
already love like thousands of people
are so into these books all over the
world
um and so the chemistry already existed
it was on the page i think that these
two people are very lucky
to find someone else who is as witty and
sparky i think they're both the types of
people who are used to being the
smartest person in the room
and the second they find someone who is
up to the challenge of kind of really
sparring with them on an intellectual
level
is hugely enticing and so they get a bit
of a bit of a brain gasm over each other
okay now were you talking so i'm
bringing them that's a good word now
were you saying something about the
dance and the choreography were you guys
stepping on each other's feet
um only for a little while uh we had a
lot of rehearsal um
and then after those rehearsals we
decided to do some more rehearsal
because we
enjoyed dancing so much and also we
probably needed it
um but there was something doing the
dancing in the costumes
oh it was so fun it was so it was such a
magical experience i mean
i know me and reggae have talked about
this but one of my favorite scenes was
like
in the first episode at the end um
there's like this beautiful sequence and
it was one of the first scenes we shot
and it was outside and there were
fireworks actually going off in the
background and it was the first time we
got to perform or dance we were both
kind of nervous about it but
the feeling when we were doing it was
just it was such a magical experience
and and there was no cgi involved
in that scene it was all there it was
all happening around us and
and it was such a magical experience and
watching it i think it
it does really it it shows on the screen
i think as well which is
great well it definitely does the show's
so addictive and julie andrews i mean
hello
yeah yeah absolutely we could get to say
hello the mysterious julie andrews
narrating from afar
it's kind of you kind of get to feel the
end of her consonants
amazing well congratulations on the show
you guys thank you very much appreciate
it